ahora vamos a sacar unos límites
involucrando funciones compuestas
entonces vamos a ver el primero aquí
tenemos el límite cuando extiende a tres
dejen de htx y como siempre te invito
para usar el vídeo y que veas si puedes
resolverlo por tu cuenta bien podemos
aprovechar nuestras propiedades de los
límites y gracias a ellas sabemos que
esto va a ser lo mismo que gm de el
límite cuando extiende a tres de htx así
que solamente tenemos que encontrar
cuánto valen el límite cuando extiende a
tres de hdx y para eso vamos a usar la
gráfica de hd x lo primero que quiero
que veas es que ht3 está en definida
pero podemos pensar cuál es el límite de
hd x cuando extiende a 3 si observas
cuando extiende a 3 por la izquierda
esta función se aproxima por la
izquierda a la constante 2
así que h de 2.5 es 2h de 2.9 es 2h de
2.999 99 es 2 así que parece que cuando
nos aproximamos por la izquierda
límite es 2 y cuando nos aproximamos por
la derecha tenemos lo mismo h de 3.01 es
2 h de 3.000 uno es 2h de 3.000 000001
estos entonces el límite justo aquí
cuando extiende a 3 por la derecha va a
ser 2 y eso quiere decir que acá arriba
todo esto se va a reducir simplemente a
saber cuánto vale de 2 ahora cuánto vale
g de 2 bien por aquí tenemos la gráfica
de gm así que vamos a ver cuánto vale
esta función cuando x vale 2 y bueno que
observa kg de 20 entonces todo esto acá
va a ser cero y qué creés hemos
terminado este primer límite pero vamos
a hacer unos más y para eso voy a mover
la pantalla y ahora vamos a hacer esto
de aquí tengo el límite cuando x tiende
a -1 de hd gtx bien así como acabamos de
trabajar el otro primero vamos a decir
que esto es lo mismo que h del límite
cuando extiende a menos 1 deje de x
así que vamos a tratar de encontrar el
límite cuando extiende a menos 1 dgt x
en primer lugar y por eso aquí tengo la
gráfica
de x y podemos ver justo aquí que en x
igual a menos 1 tenemos esta
discontinuidad a medida que nos
aproximamos a x igual a menos 1 por la
izquierda parece que tendemos a menos
infinito en dirección negativa a observa
no está acotado ya medida que nos
acercamos a x igual a menos 1 por el
lado derecho parece que nos estamos
acercando al infinito positivo así que
incluso si ambos estuvieran
aproximándose a la misma dirección de
infinito diríamos que el límite no está
definido ya que menos porque uno de esos
límites está yendo a infinito positivo y
el otro está yendo a infinito negativo
así que en definitiva este límite no
existen déjame ponerlo este límite no
existe entonces si queremos el límite
cuando extiende a menos uno de gtx no
existe entonces como ya sabemos que el
límite cuando extiende a menos uno gtx
no existe entonces no hay manera de que
pueda
evaluar esta expresión no podemos
encontrar h
no existen entonces todo este límite
completo no existe bien vamos a hacer
uno más de estos voy a mover la pantalla
y ahora vamos a trabajar con este de
aquí tengo el límite cuando extiende al
menos tres de hd fx y bueno ya lo vimos
esto es lo mismo que h de el límite
cuando extiende a menos tres de fx así
que veamos a fx
esta es la gráfica de igual a fx y luego
pensemos en el límite cuando extiende al
menos tres bien observa que a medida que
nos aproximamos a menos tres por el lado
izquierdo a medida que nos acercamos más
y más y más a menos tres parece que nos
estamos aproximando al valor de uno ya
medida que nos aproximamos por el lado
derecho parece que nos estamos acercando
también al valor de uno si tuviera que
tomar algunos valores por el lado
izquierdo por ejemplo menos 3.1 menos
3.0 1 menos 3.000 1 voy a estar más y
más y más cerca de obtener
de 1 ene efe y observa que lo mismo pasa
en el lado derecho así que esto parece
que es 1 es límite de aquí va a ser 1 y
ahora solamente tenemos que evaluar
cuánto es
ht 1 y para eso vamos a usar la gráfica
de h ahora cuando en esta gráfica
tomamos el valor de 1 observa que esta
función no está definida así que hd 1 en
realidad es indefinida observa que en
este caso el límite no existiría en este
caso la parte del límite era en realidad
lo más sencillo encontrar el límite de
fx fue bastante sencillo pero luego
cuando tratamos de ponerlo como entrada
en hd x encontramos que hdx en ese valor
era indefinida